PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Good morning,
and welcome to Playtime 2018.
Thank you for joining us today.
Who recognizes this?
Ha-ha.
Couple days ago, I heard
that Android market
was launched almost to
the date 10 years ago.
I saw some show of hands.
How many people had an
app on Android market?
Wow, that's awesome.
I joined four years later
when Play just got launched.
It was a simpler time, but one
with lots of uncertainties.
I remember having conversations
with lots of you in this room
and wondering, will people
ever pay for apps and games
on Android?
Remember those conversations?
And Playtime was a
small group of us
in a conference room at
Google Mountain View.
Look how far we have come.
Today, together we have built a
thriving, multi-billion-dollar
industry.
You have identified needs we
did not even think existed
and created new markets
for self-driving--
sorry, ride sharing,
not self-driving yet,
right, for ride sharing,
hunting Pokemons,
for finding customized
fitness, et cetera.
And we have spent a lot
of time actively listening
to you to understand
how to build products
and programs to meet your need.
I was really pleased
that you feel heard.
In a recent developer
satisfaction study,
you told us that you
recognize your input
in the products and programs
we have built. I loved it.
So we're really grateful
for the active dialogue
that we've been having together
and want to continue that
so that we can build more
amazing apps and games
and thriving businesses.
So today, I want to start
with a focus on the user.
Users care about
three key things--
and I think we need to
partner on all of them--
app quality, safety and
trust, and digital well-being.
So let's start with app quality.
In this room, you represent the
highest quality apps and games.
So thank you for
your investment.
You also realize that your
investments have returns.
Your users spend
more time and money
but also recommend your
apps to other people.
We know that ensuring high
quality for everybody is hard.
And users sometimes
are unforgiving.
We see a 52% increase
in 1-star rating
when a user experiences a crash.
Therefore, we've been investing
in a set of tools called
Android Vitals to help you
measure quality in the field
and address them.
But you've told us it's
one thing to give me data.
Make it actionable.
I want to stand here and
say, we have heard you.
Today, we're going to
link the pre-launch report
to Android Vitals
to make sure you
get more actionable insights.
More will be said
about this in classroom
sessions and other
quality-related sessions.
So please attend those.
I'm also pleased to
let you know that we
are going to use quality
and long-term engagement
signals in our search
and discovery algorithms.
So thank you for your
investment in quality.
We also do a ton of
work behind the scenes.
Every app goes through an
extensive security review.
And 99% of the apps that have
any abusive content is never
seen by the user,
is taken out even
before the very first install.
After an app has been
installed, Google Play Protect
continues to monitor
the app and to make sure
that it behaves well.
If it finds that
the app isn't, it
will either notify you
or take the app away
to ensure that your
device is safe.
We scan 50 billion apps a day.
50 billion apps a day.
So it's not surprising that
a user who installs an app
exclusively from Play is nine
times less likely to come
across a harmful app than
somebody who doesn't.
But we can't do this alone.
We really can't.
We need you to partner with us
on this very, very important
area of user safety and trust.
Our goal is to make
sure that users
understand how
their data is used
and that access is reasonable.
Last week, we announced that
we are going to change access
to estimates and call log APIs.
I'm sure you've heard it.
We wanted to make sure that
the apps that use these APIs
absolutely need them.
We could not have
done it without you.
We spoke to lot of you
and took your feedback
before we made the changes.
Your input allows us to
strike that right balance
between meeting user needs and
enabling you to have and build
unique experiences.
I want to stand
here and assure you
that we will have more
such conversations
but also give you sufficient
notice to make these changes.
You know that as of November 1--
hopefully, everybody does--
that all new apps and updates
should target API 26.
Everybody's aware?
Yes?
OK.
It's a few days away.
All right.
So this is important because
it makes the user safer,
but also improves battery
life for all your apps.
Now, we announced
this 10 months ago.
And we gave very clear
guidance on how to comply.
That is how we will
continue to engage with you.
So please work with us.
My one request is for you
to keep on top of this.
How many of you know whether the
contact information on our Play
Console is up to date?
I see.
I would expect everybody
to put their hands up.
If you don't, please do.
Also, look up our newsletters.
And please engage with us
when we ask for feedback.
I want to thank
everybody who responded
to our recent developer
satisfaction study
and hope to have continue
this dialogue going forward.
So stay in touch, and
please update your contacts.
We know that safety,
security, quality,
have always been
important to our users.
But recently, people
have been thinking a lot
about striking that right
balance between using
technology and disconnecting.
This is me.
For me, it's about spending time
with family, being outside--
I love to travel--
and being in nature.
At Google, we've spent
a lot of time thinking
about digital well-being.
And at I/O, we
launched something
called a digital
well-being initiative.
We have incorporated a
bunch of capabilities
directly into Android Key.
And we're giving a
dashboard to users
to understand their digital
usage and also set controls.
They can set time limits.
They can set time to wind
down, charge, et cetera.
As businesses, you and
I have a responsibility
to respect our developers',
our users' time.
We frequently see that apps
that respect users' time have
higher long-term engagement.
Today, we want to invite
you into the dialogue
because many of you have been
thinking about this deeply
for a very long time.
This evening, I'll be
hosting a fireside chat
with Arianna Huffington
to start this dialogue
on this topic of long-term,
sustainable engagement
and our responsibility
as businesses.
She'll also share
some personal tips
on how we can work together for
our own sustained performance
and well-being.
Your own-- most of
you are leaders--
your own sustained
performance and well-being.
So I hope that all
of you will continue
to engage on these three very
important topics of quality,
safety and trust, and
digital well-being.
Now to talk about the
many other features
that we have been working
on based on your feedback,
I'm inviting on
stage Matt Henderson.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT HENDERSON: Thanks, Purnima.
And hi, everybody.
So my team and I build
Play developer products
like the Play Console.
And today, I'd like to talk
more about some play tools that
can help fuel your growth.
Today, you'll hear about
the tremendous potential
of our new smarter model
for app distribution.
We'll be talking
about features that
help you attract
new users and also
tools that help you to monetize
and grow your business.
So average app size
has grown dramatically.
It's up three times in
the last four years.
But that size growth
carries a cost.
It reduces in-store conversion.
And it increases
uninstall rates.
So this is why we built
the Android app bundle.
We announced it earlier
this year at I/O. Using it,
we're able to serve only
the code and resources
that a specific device needs.
And this enables you to
reduce the size of your app.
Well, since we launched
it just a short time ago,
thousands of Android app
bundles have reached production
all over the world.
We're really excited with
how it's progressing.
And although the size savings
varies from app to app,
on average, we're
seeing a 35% reduction
in the size, which is terrific.
We're really excited for
the potential of this.
You're going to hear
more about the bundle
and the other
benefits of smaller
apps and the possibilities with
modular apps at the session
right after this one.
So in addition to bundling
and distributing apps,
we've also introduced
new features
to help you attract
and engage users.
And one of these is
pre-registration.
So we've had pre-registration
and testing for some time now.
And it lets you gather
interest from users
before your app or game is
released in order to produce
higher day one installs.
It gathers up the demand
for that initial launch.
And since we started
testing it, we've
had more than 250 million
pre-registrations,
which is awesome.
And we're just getting started.
And today, I'm excited to
announce that pre-registration
is available to all of
our app and game partners.
And it's fully self-service
in the Play Console
So developers, also now
with pre-registration,
they have the ability to provide
a promotion that rewards people
for signing up their
interest early.
And we think that's got
great potential as well.
And additionally, we've
integrated the Google Play
Instant experience.
So this can let a user get
a taste of your app or game
prior to it actually being
ready and available to install.
And you can see
an example of this
here with the Looney
Tunes World of Mayhem.
It's the one on the left.
So we really think that
it's going to help provide
enough of a taste that
more and more people will
get into this pre-launch
interest mode.
So Google Play Instant,
it also now supports
premium apps and as an
example, on the right,
the Umiro by Devolver Digital.
With Instant, we've
also made it easier
to build with integrations
into Cocos Creator.
And a Unity plugin is
now available also.
Google Play Instant drives
incremental installs
because people get
enough of a taste of it
that they want more.
And they want to install it.
We also have another
new launch that
helps to increase in-store
conversion from the Detail
page.
So one of the top
requests from developers
has been the ability
to modify store listing
pages based on user
country not just language.
Well, now you can.
Let's walk through an example.
In this example, so Halloween
in the US and Diwali in India,
they're about a week apart,
very different events.
And users in both countries
tend to have their devices set
to US English.
So now with the country
store listing targeting,
you can change the
store listing content
based on the user's country.
So here, for two users that have
their device set to US English,
not only are the
icons and photos
different for this recipe
app in this example,
but also the description talks
about different festivals
and different features that may
be important in each country.
We think this has
great potential.
And now we've
covered features that
are going to help bring users
into your app, let's talk
about helping you
grow your business.
So our commerce platform
makes it easy for people
to safely purchase on Play in
over 150 markets via credit
card, direct carrier billing,
PayPal, and gift cards.
And the gift cards are now
available in more than 800,000
locations worldwide.
It also supports various
models like premium apps,
in-app purchasing,
and subscriptions.
And subscriptions, our
features continue to expand.
We're testing the
ability, for example,
for a user to subscribe
directly from your store listing
page from the same button
as they choose to install.
We're also testing the ability
to let users temporarily
pause a subscription
instead of canceling it.
And we're now making
it easier for you
to roll out a price change
to your existing subscribers.
You may recall at
I/O, we announced
we were starting to
test with early access
the ability for a price
change to be notified out
to existing suppliers.
Well, now we're extending
that to general availability.
You can learn more
about these features
and how they help your
subscriptions business
in a session later today.
Along with strong growth
and subscriptions,
we're seeing more developers
use a hybrid approach
to monetization.
So one trend has been to reward
users for specific action
like watching a video.
And the reward can be in-game
currency or other benefits.
Today, we're excited to
announce a new monetization
type called rewarded products.
Users can elect to
watch a short video.
And upon completion,
they're rewarded
by the developer in virtual
goods or in-game currency.
This offering is powered
by Google Ads technology.
And the implementation
uses the same API calls
that are used for in-app
purchases on Google.
No third party SDK
is required for this.
So we're currently testing
this in closed beta.
But we'll share more
details in the coming weeks.
We've covered quite a bit.
But as you know,
there's many more--
a huge range of features
that are available in Play.
And it can be tricky
for you and your teams
to understand them all.
So to help you take
advantage of all the tools
and features that
we offer, we're
launching the Academy
for App Success.
Today, there are 10 courses
that have information
ranging from managing the app's
release to granting refunds.
Going forward, we'll
support more languages.
And we're going
to be adding more
content to help
you and your teams
to take advantage of
all of the features
that Play has to offer.
So we really hope
that you check it out.
We've talked about some new
tools for growth on mobile.
But I wanted to also touch on
the broader device landscape.
So as you know, we continue
to push your apps out
to more devices with Wear
OS, Android TV, Android Auto,
and across all surfaces
with the Assistant.
Today I'd like to
focus on Chrome OS.
Hopefully, you heard
last week we launched
an exciting new device--
the Google Pixel Slate.
It's a great example of our
investment in the Chrome OS
ecosystem.
And I'd like to explain
how that growing
ecosystem is an exciting
opportunity for developers.
In just a few years, Chromebooks
has gone from a fun experiment
to being available
throughout the world.
They range from traditional
laptops to convertibles.
And they're created in
partnership with top OEMs
like Samsung, HP,
Dell, and others.
They're now available in more
than 10,000 retail locations
around the world.
And we continue to expand.
The made by Google
Pixel Slate is
designed to bring
games and apps to life
with brilliant entertainment
and portable performance.
Let's take a closer
look at a couple
of great app experiences
optimized for Chromebooks
and the Pixel Slate.
So Gameloft wanted Asphalt
8 Airborne to give users
more speed and control.
And since the Chrome OS
treats its physical keyboard
like an external keyboard
on an Android phone,
Asphalt 8 was able to support
keyboard controls using APIs
from Android SDK 26.
As a result, for
users on Chrome OS,
Asphalt 8 saw a
whopping six times
increase in daily active users
and a nine times increase
in revenue.
The Gameloft team was excited
about the strong results.
And so optimizing
for larger screens
has become standard practice.
And they've just
finished optimizing
the latest edition in their
series, Asphalt 9 Legends.
So Evernote is
another great example
of Chrome OS integration.
The Evernote team was excited to
use the low latency stylus API
to quickly implement
touchscreen handwriting
and enhance layouts
for wider screens.
Now without the
latency, their users
feel like they're actually
just drawing on paper,
which is an awesome experience.
And as a result, the
average Evernote user
now spends three times more
on larger screen devices
and four times more
time when they're
using the Google Pixelbook.
So another great
app for creators
is Adobe Premiere Rush.
It's a new video platform that
will allow people to create,
to edit, and share
videos on the go.
And the best part--
it's coming soon to Chromebooks.
So these developers went
beyond a mobile-only strategy.
They adapted their
products to serve users
on a variety of devices.
And as a result, they
got increased engagement
from users.
The same may be true for you.
Android apps are now
available on Chrome OS.
So you can take your app, and
with just a few adjustments,
optimize it for larger screens.
And if you want to get
your hands on a Slate,
look for the Chrome
booth outside.
There's a rumor going
around that they
have a bunch of Slates.
So check them out.
So that's it for me today.
There's lots of
awesome stuff to come.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]